all right guys bang bang I've got will
here with me will reflexivity research
just published a brand new q1 report on
the Bitcoin Network Bitcoin obviously
isn't a company it doesn't produce a
normal quarterly report like a public
company would and so there's been a
couple of people in the past who have
done this but you guys just put together
this report and released it to summarize
what's been going on in Bitcoin had a
monster q1 let's start with the core
network activity itself in terms of
transactions and transaction volumes
what are you guys seeing there yeah
Bitcoin passed the major Milestone this
quarter uh if you look at the cumulative
value of all the transactions the number
of transactions that have taken place on
the network bitcoin's now settled over
800 million transactions with the
cumulative value of over 107 trillion
dollars which is an incredible feed for
a fully decentralized protocol that's
only been in existence for just over 13
years when you think about active
addresses right so you talk about
transactions you talked about the value
of those transactions but is this just
like one person doing 800 million uh
transactions or is the number of active
addresses continuing to grow no yeah
absolutely when we look at the Active
addresses which is looking at sending
and receiving transactions on both sides
we can look at essentially on like a
high time frame view through a 30-day
moving average and look at what's the
kind of multi-year usage of of the
network
um and what we see is that over the last
10 years the the number of active
addresses continue to make higher lows
and so of course in a bull market you
have you know a ton of new kind of
tourists and new new network users that
come into the network because bitcoin's
price is going up uh but I think what
the what the real signal is when you
look at this metric making higher lows
is the fact that despite you know a lot
of those tourists leave heading back
into the bear Market a higher low
meaning a you know a greater amount of
people stick around during every bear
market and that's really a real sign of
adoption when people stick around
despite you know price going down 60 70
in the bear Market uh and this bear
Market has been no different we've seen
those active addresses continually
making higher lows so when we think
about Bitcoin I think a lot of folks
like okay cool it's electronic you know
peer-to-peer Cash System and that would
uh leaned itself towards those
transactions we continue to see those
cumulative numbers grow and it seems
like people are using Bitcoin to send
transactions and increase the value but
also there's a growing number of people
who simply look at Bitcoin as a store of
value they want to hold Bitcoin so one
way that you all measure this is through
how much Bitcoin sits in people's wallet
addresses and we see there that
continues to kind of grind up over time
especially over the last year or so yeah
absolutely so if we look at bitcoin's
supply distribution you know this is
something that a lot of people like to
kind of uh use as a criticism of Bitcoin
you'll see a lot of Bitcoin critics
citing the fact that a very large amount
of Bitcoin Supply is held by a very
small amount of individuals on the
network
um this frankly isn't isn't the case
when we look at the actual launching
data first of all a lot of these claims
are looking at
um you know the top 10 15 addresses on
bitcoin outright uh which a lot of those
are exchanges or custodial Solutions so
those are you know entities that are
holding Bitcoin on the behalf of
hundreds of thousands if not in case of
like a coinbase for example 100 million
plus individuals
um and so when you actually look at the
real data in terms of batching these
these transactions together labeling out
you know the exchanges and custodian
Solutions when we look at the percentage
of bitcoin's overall Supply held by
entities that hold less than 10 Bitcoin
which at a 28k bitcoin price is roughly
280 000 uh we can see that that total
value of the amount of Supply held by
those individuals with with less than 10
DC has continued to climb throughout all
bitcoin's history we've seen a real
acceleration in that over the last six
to eight months and that value is now
over 17 percent and so what what does
that mean come from kind of a first
principles basis uh showing you that
Bitcoin supply distribution is
continually becoming more favorable over
time so it's interesting because we saw
in recent weeks that Michael Saylor and
microstrategy now own 140 000 Bitcoin I
think he personally owns about 17 000 as
well so you put those two together
Michael Saylor controls somewhere around
point seven five percent right kind of
just under one percent of all Bitcoin
that will ever be in circulation and
there's a lot of folks who are yelling
and screaming and critiquing it and
saying hey that's too much concentration
obviously one point is that control of
Bitcoin uh the asset does not
necessarily give you control over the
protocol or give you control over nodes
or hash power but what you're also
saying is while maybe Michael Saylor
continues to acquire and concentrate
Bitcoin we actually are seeing the exact
opposite in kind of the smaller wallets
is becoming more decentralized yeah
absolutely
um you know when we look at something
for example like uh two different moving
averages of uh of addresses for example
so the rate of essentially change or
momentum in address growth we're also
seeing a really aggressive move up in
terms of looking for example at the
30-day moving average of non-zero
addresses relative to the 365 day moving
average and then also if we look at the
rate of growth so kind of 90-day change
or quarter over quarter change
um in those non-zero addresses we're
also seeing the highest rate of of
growth since early 2021 during bitcoin's
massive move up from from 30 to 60k as
you remember very well
um and so yeah I would say you know
while sailor is accumulating you're also
seeing in the in smaller wallets uh
really extreme accumulation from some of
these some of these smaller entities
which of course is favorable for Bitcoin
supply distribution one of the big
stories in q1 for Bitcoin was ordinals
and obviously there's a lot of
controversy there was kind of the most
hardcore Bitcoin Maximus hated it they
thought it was dumb uh they thought it
was a complete waste of time time then
there's a lot of folks who I would put
more in kind of a Bitcoin rationalist uh
camp that they're saying no look
actually this is usage of the protocol
part of the value of the protocols too
can do whatever they want with it and
obviously people want to do this what
are you all seeing in the data when it
comes to ordinals and how important was
that for the success of Bitcoin in q1
yeah it's a great question and and to
kind of summarize the kind of two camps
that I would say individuals fall into
um the first one is that
um the kind of increase in data usage on
bitcoin uh has made the download times
for individuals that are looking to
operate Bitcoin nodes uh the download
times are heightened so therefore
there's slightly more friction in terms
of people being able to download nodes
and then also individuals that fall into
this Camp have stated that you know they
don't like the fact that essentially
on-chain images are competing with
actual real economic uh transactions
that are that are looking to to get it
put into blocks on unchain uh and then I
would say the other kind of Camp uh that
I would say you and I more so fall into
um is that you know the increase in
usage of ordinals has increased the use
of of the Bitcoin blockchain and that's
translated into several measures of data
so the first one being
um if we look at Tap Root adoption right
so so ordinals were made possible
through kind of a loophole and Tapper so
if you look at Taproot adoption that's
really accelerated throughout the
quarter uh if we look at the mempool
which is essentially the backlog of
transactions that's also been the most
full that it's been in well over a year
we saw a brief Spike during kind of the
FTX collapse as there was a ton of
transactional activity and kind of
reorging of while it's going on but
overall we've seen seen the most kind of
sustainable uh filling up of the mempool
that we've seen in some time part of
that is is bitcoin's been the you know
best performing asset class of the Year
up up nearly 70 so there's definitely
some degree of just
um you know heightened activity on
bitcoin because of price outright but a
large a large degree of that is is can
be credited to ordinals um and then you
know outside of the ment pool we also
look at fees as a byproduct of that
because of course if there's more demand
to get your transaction into a block
you're going to have to raise the fees
that you're that you're willing to give
miners to incentivize them to let you
get into a block and so when we look at
Bitcoin uh transaction fees we've seen
that they've also climbed throughout the
quarter and so when you pair that
in terms of the heightened transaction
fees with the increase in the value of
daily issuance for Bitcoin you know of
course you only have 900 Bitcoin that
have that have come into circulation
every single day since the last having
change
um in 2020 and that'll change next year
as we maybe talk about that in the back
half of the conversation that I think
we're both looking forward to
um but as Bitcoins prices appreciated
throughout the quarter that's increased
the USD value of the issuance every
single day and so when you pair the
increased value of transactions with the
increased value of issuance that's
translated to when you put those two
things together overall higher USD
denominated value of revenue for minors
uh and so ultimately that's that's a
very positive thing for the security of
the network
um because when you pair that with also
Global Energy prices declining it's more
favorable for Miners and we've seen that
translated into hashrate ultimately
what's fascinating is if you look at
total transaction fees for these miners
uh over the last five six years the two
big Peaks were actually in uh the kind
of final capitulation of the 2018 bear
market right kind of Q4 of 2018 and then
in the summer of 2021 was another huge
Peak and that was kind of the the uh
Valley if you will uh when we drew down
from 60 000 to back down to 30 before we
went to an all-time high and so uh
what's interesting about the use of
ordinals here and kind of the mempool
filling up and transaction fees
increasing is this is not because of
Market volatility right this is not
necessarily being driven by a negative
event it's actually being driven by what
many people think is a positive event do
you think that that is uh important for
Bitcoin or do you think that no it's
just whenever people want to use it
whether it's because Market's going down
or there's positive impact we should
just look at it as kind of a data point
no I think it is an important
development for Bitcoin because it kind
of takes the volatility out of or
cyclicality uh out of transaction fees
for minor miners which is a positive
thing for them to have sustainable
Revenue long term and then also you know
as we look out into the future
um whenever you know the the block
subsidy goes away for minors and they're
solely relying on fees I think you and I
kind of fall into the camp of over time
um you know as Bitcoin Supply issuance
kind of plateaus out you'll see more
economic activity on chain because the
value of Bitcoin likely appreciates by
then and then you'll have more people
actually spending Bitcoin into the
overall economy but also I would say
that that ordinals add an even uh
another you know layer on top of that in
terms of potential uh activity that
could drive fees for minors over the
long term which which allows you know
the Bitcoin Network to continue to be
sustainable from an economic perspective
so this brings us to the puell multiple
uh this thing has been deadly right uh
explain what it is and then we saw kind
of second half of 2022 we hit kind of
this like green zone that everyone looks
for uh does that signal that we actually
have seen the bottom of that bear market
and we now are in the early days of the
next bull market yeah sure I would pair
this with a couple other kind of
on-chain indicators that you can look at
from like a kind of multi-year like high
time frame view of of bitcoin's clinical
Market cycles and and has kind of
behaved thus far in these like four-year
Market cycles and appears to be doing so
thus far
um first of all I would say that Bitcoin
thus far again is is following those
historical kind of uh having cycles for
for better for worse
um it's also area how how closely
they've also tied in with the broader
kind of liquidity Cycles from from
monetary policy from the FED
um but yeah looking at looking at the
pro multiple specifically
um as we mentioned earlier the the USD
value of of issuance has gone up and
that's a positive thing for miners this
is exactly what this metric tries to
tries to encapsulate so if we look at
um what what is what is from a first
principles basis this metric trying to
illustrate it's what's the what's the
USD value of minor uh issuance every day
that they're bringing in relative to the
trailing 365-day moving average so
essentially
um you know how much revenue are they
bringing in from issuance every day
relative to what they've been making
over the last year and so whenever we
see this this kind of capitulatory
behavior where we see the sharps kind of
Spike down uh into that green zone that
you talked drought which is somewhat
arbitrary based on like prior Cycles uh
what that's what's that what that's
indicating is partially a byproduct of
price but just that miners under extreme
stress so whenever we get to the bottom
of every single Bitcoin cycle uh you see
miners kind of
um you know sustainability or viability
tested in terms of you know how they're
running their operations we saw a major
minor capitulation at the back half of
2018 and as we saw this Spike down on
the pull multiple in the back half of
this year I'm sorry in the back half of
2022 into the beginning of this year uh
we saw kind of similar capitulatory
behavior in terms of hash rate coming
offline and looking at some like moving
averages of hash rate that have kind of
indicated capitulation for miners as
well as selling for minors in terms of
looking at the on-chain wallets
um so yeah this this kind of uh from a
like cyclical
perspective marked this like very
similar behaviors to what we saw in 2018
and also in 2015 as well
um and then you know from from kind of a
forward-looking perspective what does
this indicate well it indicates that
potentially the worst is behind us four
miners uh and then again kind of what I
mentioned towards towards the beginning
of the conversation when we talk about
ordinals um it's taken some of the
pressure off of off of minor margins
which
um as kind of a second order effect of
that likely decreases the amount of cell
pressure that's going to come online
because miners no longer have to sell
their Bitcoin to kind of keep the lights
on yeah when you think about something
like the lightning Network I know that
you guys didn't spend a ton of time
doing the analysis uh for the lightning
Network for this specific report but it
seems like the lightning Network
continues to gain adoption and continues
to kind of grow at an impressive pace is
that a fair way to characterize it yeah
I would say the lightning network has
held up quite well over the last few
quarters You know despite the kind of
like broader market decline in Bitcoin I
think that kind of shows you that
there's actual real uh underlying
utility for the lightning Network being
used for things like remittances and you
know there's the Bitcoin beach in El
Salvador that's kind of the most famous
example of that when we look at the USD
value of lightning network capacity
granted this is just public data it's
increased by 50 million a quarter over
quarter and overall it's held up quite
well I would say but we haven't really
seen that kind of breakthrough point of
adoption for for the lightning Network
yet but with people like Jack Mahler
strike and some of these other kind of
lightning Network companies uh I think
we're probably well on the way to it's
kind of just a waiting game for for
seeing that kind of breakthrough in an
application to push the lightning
Network forward yeah we mentioned
earlier the idea that the having is
coming right it's kind of next year in
the past regardless of what people think
it has had an impact on price it's very
obvious there's the having and then
there's this price uh kind of movement
upwards uh what is your expectation
going into it what are you looking for
are there certain things that would be
red flags to you as we head towards that
having what does the having mean for
anyone who doesn't know it means that
the amount of Bitcoin that come into
circulation is going to be cut in half
so it's going to go from 900 Bitcoin uh
every day to uh 450 that had come out
into circulation every single day and so
in theory if you have the same you know
amount of demand and then a decreased
amount of Supply that's coming into
circulation that could that should cause
an upward shift in price
um in terms of you know I'm like a
multi-year view I think that's a very
positive thing for bitcoin's Price
action uh but in terms of what I would
be watching leading up to the having I
would say keep a very close eye on the
derivatives data because that'll kind of
give you some some signals as to how the
Market's positioned so in markets it's
not always about whether something's a
positive or negative thing it's about
you know how positive or how negative is
this event relative to the Market's
expectations
um so I would say if you see in the
derivatives data that you know seeing
things like high funding rates along
with you know High open interest uh
that's potentially indicating that
Traders are you know maybe getting a
little overly bullish
um locally uh in terms of you know prior
to the having and this is something that
we saw uh in 2020 we saw
um of course the Kobe crash plate played
a big role in this but we saw in in the
derivatives data uh drives essentially
got jacked leading up into the having we
saw funding rates extremely high open
interest was climbing so essentially a
bunch of individuals understood that
um you know on a multi-year view the
having was a bullish thing but maybe
locally uh kind of levered up a little
too much and then we had kind of coveted
that came in and exacerbated a
liquidation Cascade and wiped all that
leverage out hopefully we don't have
another type coveted like event that uh
that will cause any type of Leverage to
get flushed out to that extent but uh I
guess the point I'm just saying is keep
an eye on the positioning of of the
individuals uh heading into the having
to understand locally uh how maybe it'll
it'll play out potentially be a sell the
news event you know on like a short-term
basis so we've seen narratives be
incredibly important to bitcoin over the
years there was obviously you know
institutions are coming corporates are
buying uh everything from regulation El
Salvador Etc
um we talked about ordinals there's
obviously the lightning Network story uh
there's this idea of very high
illiquidity in the market are there any
other narratives you're paying attention
to right now that you think are worth
calling out yeah absolutely I'll say one
thing on the on the liquidity thing you
know this is something that we we talked
about actually a lot in 2021 and I would
say where where I was wrong was yes I
would say the the overall Supply was was
relatively illiquid in terms of being
held by entities that had a low
likelihood of moving those coins again
um but you know that that'll look that
illiquidity can be exacerbated in both
directions and so I think the fact that
there was such a low circulating float
of Bitcoin exacerbated a lot of the
downside the kind of back half of of
um but you know on the on the converse
of that
um you know if we do see some type of
you know upwards price action that's
likely to get accelerated by the fact
that uh there's a large amount of
Bitcoin that's held by
um on-chain entities that are have a
very low likelihood to sell over 70 of
Bitcoins held by long-term holders uh
all-time high amount of Supply that
hasn't moved in at least a year two
years uh and so yeah I would say the the
available float is is at the lowest that
it's ever been uh and so when
individuals come come looking to buy
Bitcoin I think there's a lot of Bitcoin
holders that have gotten their uh belief
tested over the last two years uh and at
least based on the data that we're
currently seeing aren't looking to sell
anytime soon in terms of narratives that
I would say to watch out for I think a
lot of individuals are kind of
underestimating the geopolitical
significance of Bitcoin
um you know as we continue to see some
of these headlines of uh countries
looking to price oil in Juan for example
and potentially looking to move off a US
dollar standard I don't think the dollar
is going away next week like some
individuals maybe have have mentioned
but I do think you know there's there's
likely a relationship or correlation
between as we see more headlines of of
countries looking to move away from from
a dollar standard slowly uh the higher
the likelihood is that they have some
type of at least you know like a small
hedge a small position in Bitcoin and so
something I would I would keep an eye
out for is some of these countries like
UAE Singapore Etc uh potentially taking
some type of small Bitcoin allocation
and I wouldn't be surprised to see that
you know announced over the last few
years yeah I mean that would be a pretty
big development and pretty incredible
um where can people go find you online
or find out more about reflexivity
research if they want to get this in
their inbox yeah absolutely you can
check out reflexivity at reflexivity
research.com we're also on Twitter
reflexivity res and then you can check
me out on Twitter at wclementi awesome
well anyone who wants uh highly suggest
go and subscribe reflexivity research
these guys are doing a fantastic job uh
digging into the data they are creating
all sorts of different reports
um and I've been learning a lot from
them and it's pretty cool to be working
with Will and the rest of the team so if
you want go check it out
reflexivityresearch.com I appreciate you
doing this we'll do it again in the
future thanks Paul talk to you next week